loved fantasy books growing up but I
rarely saw people in them who looked
like me I didn't see black girls as the
main characters going on these magical
adventures and I used to wonder why is
that and so as an adult I said hmm well
why not make that so why not write that
book that little Angie would have loved
to have read and even said it somewhere
that she knows so part of the book takes
place in Jackson Mississippi which you
know it doesn't seem like a magical
place but for me it was growing up and
so I get to make it magical in this book
plus I get to unveil like a big secret
about Jackson there's a volcano under
Jackson and nobody knows a lot of people
don't know that way
there is a real inactive volcano under
the city of Jackson so I got to explore
that in the book too and I know Jackson
kids are going to be like what